[Music]
just when you thought it was safe to go
back on the youtube we didn't know
and youtube would just his eyes roll
over white
was my mic not on
is it on now oh geez i was just saying
stupid things so glad to be back with
you uh youtube uh it's been a long time
coming by long time i mean one week
so look uh what would help is if you
like share the show um leave a comment
because obviously the algorithms act as
so you don't exist after a week but i
wanted to talk with you about something
before we start and we have an intro
here for you um that you haven't seen in
a long time
uh
we were streaming just so you know if
we're not here on youtube and you don't
see a notification we're always on
rumble right monday through thursday 10
a.m eastern and we're always on mug club
and i think we have the promo code it's
free speech you can get 30 off we always
recommend that you go there it's the
easiest way so you don't have to switch
over to the you know the bonus show but
here's something it's pretty interesting
here
and i'm really happy
to be able to discuss that once upon a
time there was no other game in town
we're not quite there yet
just to let you know
but
let me show you some screen grabs here
before we started streaming to rumble uh
last week a week ago rumble was not even
in the top 10 apps on the app store
okay
when we streamed to rumble that first
monday thank you because of you
we had 95 000 people watching i think we
have a screen grab that uh someone wrote
an article
90 something thousand it was the highest
number outside of youtube for a stream
like that
and of course andrew tate got banned he
came over midweek
and now rumble is the number one
uh app in its category or at least it
was at the time that i checked it uh
this morning
look rumble is nowhere near the size of
youtube and i'm not saying that we're
putting all of our eggs in that basket i
would like to see any competitor out
there do really well we've just seen the
most amount of promise with rumble i
don't work for rumble uh they've just
been very hospitable to us and allowed
us to stream so that when we get banned
from youtube we have a place to go but
this is proof
you
for the first time
that it is possible for you to migrate
and actually help determine the market
if you go somewhere else off of youtube
95 000 people
of you at any given second and that's
not including mug club we're watching
somewhere other than you nothing would
make me happier than eventually to be
able to never have to talk
to you through youtube ever again we
didn't have that option and we have to
be here for a while longer but this is a
big step and it is a step
you are the one who you hold the power
in determining
what amount of power big tech wields
over you and elections and we're going
to get into that here today
zuckerberg on joe rogan talking about
the fbi throttling the hunter biden
laptop story and of course we were
banned just to be clear because of
carrie lake discussing issues
in the election in arizona that she won
but let me just say this even if there
is and there has never been any cheating
whatsoever of course as we all know in
any election since the beginning of this
country
we would never imply otherwise most safe
and secure ever
it's not needed
if they can throttle if they can control
the information like
shadow banning the hunter biden laptop
story which we now know
occurred
and we now know
that alone changed the outcome of the
election
i'll get into that number by number
state by state in today's show they
don't even need to cheat
because of the lobbyists and because of
the power that only a handful of
organizations wield and for the first
time
you
are making them sweat
we're not there yet but i am telling you
this is
this is a big step and it's one that i'm
really really happy to report
uh this is a multiple
of any time we've ever streamed
somewhere else and i thank you for
following us over and if ever we get
suspended here again
when we get suspended here again
i ask that you do the same
and i look forward to seeing you
wherever it is that we land but the good
news is we can now land somewhere else
chin up and it's time to fight like hell
figuratively figuratively we'll get into
that too here's the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
30 seconds
god be with you all right guys this is
it 2020 move fast and avoid getting
those community guidelines striking i
want regular content from all you it's
an election year so use those algorithms
you're not sure if your content's
borderline air on the side of caution we
don't need any more channels being bad
keep your content clean gentlemen
i'll see you on youtube
okay let me show you boys
oh
bring it down
captain you've got
it i don't know how much more control
don't think like that i promise you
after this i'll buy everyone here around
to fear okay even brandon thank you sir
because he got a salute he was gonna
loan that's not protocol
corporal black tell me you have some
good news for right now captain there's
hardly anybody left they took out gather
trigger you got ambushed [ __ ] shapiro's
gone and it gets worse it shouldn't get
any worse it's just box
videos doll unboxings and makeup
tutorials with training
we need to surrender come on we didn't
come all this way just to give it up for
some silicon valley sprite right
what's your name private give and serve
he's not in our company but he's still
here that's a good sign it's an election
year david we created mug club exactly
for this instant to guarantee a future
free internet for all content creators
free from the legacy media gatekeepers
that's why we're here don't forget that
i want you to look alive get out move up
and use maddie as cover three two
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's a satisfied sip because
you can't keep a good man down i guess
we can't keep
this guy down uh whatever it is
glad to be back with you here on youtube
i know some of you not thrilled that we
are back here on youtube and actually
that's my question of the day if you
caught this show
but we were not on youtube where did you
watch and comment below was it rumble uh
were you downloading on apple you know
spotify uh android wherever it's
available sorry hold on a second i have
a burp right on the outside of the show
the audio podcast yeah that's that's my
stars
i love it that was look my mute button
works you still heard that every mic
caught it i apologize i did not i really
tried to mute them
welcome back to youtube every mic caught
it
so we have a lot to get to today uh our
team here by the way infiltrated a drag
show in texas and that's going to be
coming up thursday we have a teaser for
you uh the the the cnn is freaking out
now because lindsey graham said that if
there's this you know investigation
prosecution of donald trump that it
could result in riots in the streets of
course he didn't condone it uh but
they're trying to act as though it's a
call to violence i think we're a little
bit familiar with that and then really
telling is that the face the facebook
the book of the faces
worked with the fbi you know this uh
zuckerberg talked about this on joe
rogan uh to throttle the hunter biden
story what you may not know is that that
would have changed the face of the
election period
there is no debate about it according to
biden voters
themselves
so it doesn't matter if there's cheating
that takes place which of course we
would never apply there never never
implied ever no if you control the flow
of information on facebook instagram
twitter
i guess youtube google and maybe tick
tock you can throw it in there you
control the information there you can
control elections and boy is it good
that there are going to be some
alternatives uh but before we move on
with anything else gerald how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing well
you were in short sleeves nothing like
uh dressing up thank you yeah do my best
speaking of dressing up uh you know him
you love him the fastest man on his feet
and we are going to be on tour the big
show coming up louder with crowder.com
get your tickets september 17th at the
smart financial center in sugar land
dave landau how are you ahoy good how
about you i'm doing well thanks
uh phoenix is phoenix is mostly sold out
there's like 100 tickets left and i
don't want to advertise it because there
aren't more than like a couple seats
that are you know you can sit with one
person but that's it we're looking at
you houston yes you lonely men yes
all you incels
no dates you want to get yourself a lady
press your pants
perfume your bed sheets wear short
sleeves i decided to give you a coat
torso friend yes yeah
so okay before i move on that we have so
much to get to here today and uh it's
weird because it's kind of you would
assume a slow news day but it's a slow
news day because the media really
doesn't want to cover what has taken
place really from friday to now
and some of it i hate to use the term
nuance but there's some subtext that has
been missed but before that let's start
with something a little bit on the nose
uh drew barrymore i don't know if you
know this people were complaining she
was trending she's did you know she's a
racist yes yes really why because she
likes
uh
enjoying rainfall yeah
you and i both know
that you are capable of enjoying the
rain
and frolicking freely without filming it
and then posting it to tick tock
now you've just co-signed
okay you just co-signed at least 3
million 8.5 by 11 front and back
people who just
go out of their way
to disrespect and
dismiss the boundaries that black
creators have set
and now you're one of those created the
rain so
i guess my question would be
why
why why is it so important to all of you
to treat us like
we don't matter
i feel like you're reaching i would
think so too that being said she also uh
protested the uh clear clear clear
wadden's clear i can't get the name of
cretin's clear water revival
yeah
have you ever
seen no it's right now
no
she's fun at parties
you appropriated janine's glasses from
ghostbusters yes also rosaries and
hanging them from her glasses
how could you you could also have said
that to somebody and not recorded it and
posted it to tick-tock that's true but
what's even scarier is the response a
lot of people agree well of course they
did because it's stupid yes that's a
good point
but andrew tate is a threat to democracy
do you have any idea what this lady
would do if you gave her a scepter and
made her queen for a day give any idea
what kind of racism what kind of
genocide would take place this this
broad is pissed off that drew barrymore
was enjoying the rain well she's more
pissed off that she filmed it and posted
it i'm like well then what is tick tock
for drew barrymore was a child star
let's just let her have that one yes all
right she's had a very rough and she's
not just dead yet that's great yeah
grateful it's not falling coke yeah it's
really i mean she's been decorated like
a harvey weinstein ficus i mean it's
just it is absolutely mind-numbing that
but people get mad about it and i look i
will say this to to give
to give the give them one it does seem
entirely ridiculous on its face but
rain specifically in dancing in the rain
actually does have there is some history
there steeped
in white supremacy you may have missed
i'm laughing at clouds
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know how i missed that on first
watch in plain sight yeah that's true
yeah wow i think it's because it's
soaked in gas it just kept yeah i think
he was trying to just throw us off the
scent that he was gay yeah
that guy went for love all right no i
assume i mean no way danny k definitely
wasn't trying to uh to bow for the king
i thought that was all man yeah
it's hard to tell gosh this is where we
when it's beyond parody like you notice
we don't even say anything during
everyone here you could have heard a pin
drop in the studio at that lady who was
furious with drew barrymore because
there's nothing to add to that
i was trying to figure out why she was
angry i still don't really know
i don't know what boundaries were set by
black creators like she said that we
crossed
and you find some write-ups if you
search this because climate change
disproportionately affects people in
poverty and minorities
and rain is climate change that's what
they say
that's what they were saying on the
twitter and tickets they do know that
that's what plants need to surviving
well it's too by the way
it's really what the planet needs it's
bronzer everything's got electrolytes
[Laughter]
all right
so this is something else before we move
on to something that you're all familiar
with uh sunday this is exclusive here uh
anderson distillery in renault texas
roanoke
roanoke
yeah roanoke roanoke roanoke i don't
care they're they're going down
okay uh just like gene kelly yeah they
uh hosted what they called a
family-friendly
drag show with children and um
we sent our team out there i don't want
to reveal too much yet but we were on
the ground both behind the scenes and
reporting and many of these people don't
know that we were behind the scenes but
it's going to be
released on thursday
here's a sneak peek at the family
friendly drag show
how are y'all doing
[Music]
y'all doing all right
all right
[Music]
well thank you for not shooting anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can report
[Music]
i thought that guy too with the face he
had the full face dress and he had that
but he had a little rainbow wrap he was
like the like the iron geek
i just like all of it yeah
all right but those were not uh armed
security guards that were hired to
protect the event either no it was
antifa black block with uh ar-15s yeah
which is just funny because they had to
buy a custom shoulder strap because
they don't come in that wide oh
just girthy just you can escape them by
walking at a slightly brisk pace
it zigzag very slow yes exactly
this is where this is happening all
across the country just so you know we
just happened to go down to one this is
not fringe
this is something that is happening all
across the country so when the left says
you're not allowed to say
pedophiles or sexualization of children
i think media matters around the clip
where there's a disproportionate number
of uh you know uh sex offenders in the
transgender community specifically we
were talking about the drag queen story
hour
yeah i stand by it they ran a story for
us yeah good of course of course i stand
back i think it should already be a sex
offense to have uh six-year-olds putting
dollar bills in your in your long john
panties
call me old-fashioned it should be at
least frowned upon yes should it you
should at least feel some sort of shame
wonder shame when can we bring back
shame no can't do it
all right so uh here's something shame
uh i wanted to see if you guys had uh
had watched this and maybe if you missed
some subtext comment uh my question to
you you can comment below
if
the hair on the back of your neck stood
up when you watched zuckerberg on joe
rogan and what's funny is i remember one
time when i was on with joe talking
about zuckerberg at length making fun of
him for seeming robotic and like a
sociopath yeah and i think that joe did
a
he did a good job i would have liked to
see him hold his feet to the fire a
little bit more but i understand that
joe wants to make people comfortable he
does a good job with that but
zuckerberg was on there and have you
watched this yet dave i watched part of
it okay yeah i did watch it's very eerie
yeah uh mark zuckerberg
sorry no it's okay watching this part
was very eerie yeah it's it's scary and
it's scary when you understand the
outcome so i want you to hear what he's
saying it's a little bit of a long clip
here but you need to have the entire
context you can go watch the whole thing
on spotify that's where joe rogan um
streams another alternative
uh right now ish um
zuckerberg
just plain out revealed
that facebook censored the hunter by the
laptop story specifically because of
someone who's been the news quite a bit
lately
the fbi
watch this
how do you guys handle things when
they're uh a big news item that's
controversial like there was a lot of
attention on twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new year
yeah we chose to yeah so you guys
censored that as well
so we took a different path than twitter
um i mean basically the background here
is the fbi i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was
we doesn't even realize what he just
said
2016 election we have it on notice that
basically there's about to be
some kind of dump of of um
uh
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant so they found check for the
fact checks
what twitter did is they said you can't
share this at all um we didn't do that
what we do
have
yeah if something is reported to us as
potentially
um misinformation important
misinformation
we also this third party fact-checking
program because we don't want to be
deciding what's true and false and
for the
i think it was
five or seven days when it was basically
being
um
being determined whether it was false
the distribution on facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it
the distribution has decreased it got
shared how does that work basically the
ranking and news feed was a little bit
less oh a little so fewer people saw it
than would have otherwise so it
definitely by what percentage i don't
know off the top of my head but yes you
do it's it's meaningful
yes you do
yes you do i'm not in the business of
attributing motive or saying that
someone is yes you do you do know off
the top of your head and by this is the
problem is well we have third party fact
checking hold on a second
the fbi is one of the fact you just said
the fbi is a fact checker because they
told you it was misinformation you used
the word of the f who fact checks the
fbi
this is the problem with the raid going
on right now who holds the people
accountable
whose job it is to hold everyone else
accountable when they have now gone
rogue
you have to believe one of two things
here either the fbi is so absolutely
inept that they couldn't be bothered to
ring ring giuliani where'd you get that
laptop oh do you have the receipt from
geek squad you do let's go check it out
you have to believe that they are so
inept they aren't able to do what we did
on this show keep in mind the laptop was
shown on this show for the first time to
the public when giuliani was on this
show the hunter buying laptop we
confirmed it
they're either so inept or they're lying
and tried to affect the outcome of the
election there is no door number three
and we have a third party fact checkers
okay so the fbi is one of them who else
southern poverty law center yeah the cdc
the wh so with youtube who fact checks
the fact checkers especially now when
the cdc said sorry we were wrong about a
lot
but what's ridiculous is the language
just that he says well we made it
shareable just less so exactly it's like
well why didn't you say we made it less
shareable wouldn't that sound way worse
because it's what you said right i mean
the way that if you just move a couple
words in his responses it becomes way
creepier right than what he actually
says and this is what they do see
okay people talk about that for example
sometimes in the bible if you look at it
they're like they talk about uh
in revelations like giant metal
screaming birds and now you go back oh
that maybe someone was trying to
describe a plane right how would you
describe it if the word plane didn't
exist for the longest time the term that
we used as conservatives right was
shadow band there was no term industry
term we just know that there was code
baked into your page for example
we've had legal uh tussles hootenannies
i guess we can say with facebook never
lost a one when they were throttling our
content on your pages it was verified
confirmed by uh engadget or gizmodo
released publicly so we use the term
shadow band because there is no term at
that point in time that exists what they
do is they say oh you're a conspiracy
there's no such thing as shadow banning
we have never used the term shadow
banning at facebook well on a second
we're just using it
you know shorthand to say you throttle
contents but it's less shareable and
people can't see oh well we do we do
that we do that yeah we let it show up
in the newsfeed and i love how at the
end he was like oh it's it's meaningful
yeah yeah everything that shows up in
the news feed is meaningful that's where
people go to get updates on what's
happening in society after they've
scrolled through their page for a little
bit and get bored hey uh kevin lane
gunderson get that number from how many
people are on facebook the number of
people who consume their news from
facebook the numbers are shocking yeah
it's somewhere from 70 to 90 which is
meaningful right it's insane yeah when
you consider that's the that's people's
portal in a lot of countries as to where
they get news and this is the important
is they try to gaslight you if you say
shadow band they go oh it's not a thing
these crazy conservative conspiracy
theories and then what happens is shadow
ban becomes a trigger word so that they
throttle your content claiming that
there's no shadow banning now
to be completely clear before you
fact-check us now the fbi did respond
saying that they can only inform
private entities of threats not require
them to take action now that may be uh
but of course given what we've discussed
before here the political leanings of
people at meta used to be facebook when
this happened uh it's 6.9 million to
democrats in 2020 compared to under 600
000 to republicans and there are a lot
of ways to hide the money as well but
they overwhelmingly give to democrats
they overwhelmingly support democrats
and by the way the shadow banning how
can all of the mistakes only go one way
hi we're the fbi we're here to make a
casual suggestion yes that's how they
typically operate yes that's a nice
picture of your wife no
yeah
that happened in real life shame if
something happened to him oh he goes to
that uh he goes to that montessori
school over there on uh on plainwood
boulevard doesn't he yes
beautiful strawberry blonde hair that he
has yes looks like he's at lunch right
now
don't worry we won't send any of the cia
after them i know they they love the
kids but uh only if you check their hard
drives right the worst thing about this
is that what he's saying by the way uh
pew research
shows about a third of americans
regularly get their news from facebook a
third third
yeah and it's even higher in other
countries yeah absolutely one of the
worst things about this is that what he
said was oh the fbi just warned us
misinformation coming from russia well
then why did you flag this story right
what about this story everyone knew this
was real and by the way they did the
same thing with the ashley biden
diary just to be clear right
she was
according to ashley biden let me just
make sure according to ashley biden her
diary her diary
she was molested according to ashley
biden she was sexualized at a young age
according to ashley biden she showered
with her dad beyond the point that was
age appropriate remember what they said
this is uh this is a false story then
they said this must have been stolen now
they're prosecuting someone for selling
it turns out it wasn't actually stolen
it was something that was left and was
abandoned yes well they're getting a
prison sentence right they're not
prosecuting anymore why would you get a
prison sentence for a fake diary
remember that's what we heard exactly
but it's believable women right but
especially biden yes well unless it's in
writing yes as well i believe it's a
calligraphy term yes believe all women
but ash and here's something else too
the fbs is we can only inform them well
here's one thing on youtube you have
community guidelines okay then you have
advertiser friendly guidelines then you
have borderline content
we don't know you don't know
nobody knows who determines what is
borderline content they just say well we
have a panel we have a group of
different people who inform us who
we it's a rule that is broad that is
opaque that isn't defined and we have no
idea who's enforcing it could that be an
example of the fbi saying we just
suggest that that is
borderline content this is the problem
with three with 320 right this is the
problem with the or sorry 230 30 this is
i was getting 4 20 in section 230
confused
watch i just said 420 and there are a
bunch of people
that'll inspire them to comment you said
it everything else look got a weed belt
buckle
and a hat and a shirt i don't have any
weed though i spent it all on this and
not a job
no with section 230 is
if you are a if you're a platform and
not a publisher you need to let people
know you can't be a platform and have
the fbi telling you what you can and
can't post now
here's what's so scary about this
there's never been any cheating in any
election elizabeth elizabeth warren amy
klobuchar they were wrong jimmy carter
kamala harris hillary clinton hillary
clinton they they deserve to be locked
up for their election conspiracies i
cannot believe that they would want to
sow mistrust in our institution the
institutions those [ __ ] so
according to
yes
according to the polling though let's
get rid of the no cheating that never
ever ever ever happened right carrie
lake watch your mouth
uh according to the polls 17 percent of
biden voters
said they would have changed their vote
or not voted had they known about the
hunter biden laptop story and dave made
a great point it's not just about the
fact that he was smoking crack and
sexting his niece it's about the fact
that he was directly involving his dad
in foreign business deals uh with
governments who do not have americans
best interest at heart that does matter
i don't care what sam harris says he's
stupid
so take this into account 17
17
would have changed their vote
biden voters
okay
let's change that electoral map donald
trump would have won arizona by 273 000
votes georgia 408 000 votes nevada 85
000 votes michigan over 300 000 votes
new hampshire 12 000. that's a low
number because it's a small state no one
cares about pennsylvania 507 000 votes
wisconsin donald trump would have won
minnesota donald trump would have won if
you if you cut the number in half by the
people who answered the poll saying they
would have changed their vote it still
would have been a ronald reagan-like
landslide through the electoral college
just that one story
just that one story
well we don't know you know are bad no
no no no more you're bad these
organizations cannot any libertarian
says they're a private company they can
do whatever they want do you still
believe that do you still believe
they're a private company when they are
removing a story that has a direct
effect on the ala
on the election outcome
based on the suggestion by the fbi
this is not some private business doing
what private business do
no and the interesting part to me is you
know all the flack that donald trump has
been given for maybe you know being soft
on russia doing business deals with
russia that the two people that were
implicated or two countries implicated
in this laptop were ukraine and china
we've been really really soft on china
trying to take every step that we can to
take away a lot of the provisions that
donald trump put in place economically a
lot of the sanctions a lot of not
sanctions sorry the the tariffs
and we're sending over billions and
billions and billions of dollars to
where ukraine
i'm not saying anything i'm just saying
it's very weird to me right now that
that is that that's the claim those are
the two places and those are the two
places right now and nobody's making
that argument that i'm seeing at all
right other than not liking their money
going to ukraine i think you following
logic in a straight line is the wrong
way to go it makes me feel like i'm
starting a conspiracy on accident
because it's like oh well that makes
sense just a b and c is not the way to
do it yeah he's why don't you you've
been spending too much time in the rain
yeah there's a reddit thread for me
somewhere racist
this is where we are and they want to
gaslight you into thinking that you're
crazy you're not crazy and by the way i
don't think those those biden voters who
said they would change their vote are
crazy i think they're uninformed and by
god it's really hard to be informed
today we have more access to information
than ever think about that for a second
when we when we were
the age of some of the generate you know
generations of entering the workforce
when we were teenagers we would have to
go down to a library we have to take a
book out you know they used to have
encyclopedia door-to-door salesman not
anymore nowadays you can access all
information at your fingertips however
it is more curated than ever before and
people are more misinformed than ever
before
and the people who voted for biden 70 of
them said oh my god that would have
changed how i viewed the world and how i
would have voted but these are just
private entities and that's why i ask
that you like right now just hit the
like button uh and go over to rumble
right now if you're on youtube go over
to rumble i would love to see you at
rumble we just we have to stream here
until all of you guys convert there's
still millions of you who have not
converted yet
um millions like the votes yes no no no
no no sorry no no no no no no no no
according to what they said recording
yes yes
but you should shut your mouth too just
like carrie lake no no i didn't mean in
real life i meant hypothetical to what
we discussed based on a poll yes i
understand and that i don't
right
uh
i mean the poll we're allowed to share
because it's a poll yes yes yes exactly
and by the way all the references are
available at loudouthcrider.com we make
them available so that hopefully you can
do some research and be informed
yourself i need to apologize by the way
for last thursday people were saying
where was the show we had some tech
difficulties where we everything was
just corrupted
the entire show that we did here gone
forever yep thank god
um but we did some investigating just so
you know there we won't have that
problem again um we actually there were
there were wiring problems oh yeah
some pest control problems here in the
studio and we actually we caught the
culprit
brian stiltzer
yes it's i
heterosexual former news anchor brian
stelter and i've been nibbling on your
wires hey come here come here no unhand
me unhand me except for you you can hand
me some more oh no
no stop it
no yeah you more though
oh man
i don't know why we gave him the
passcode
i'm not sure i had a feeling he was
gonna nibble the wires you know i paid
him the stipend but he never came into
work that's weird he thought that was
work he thinks his work is snacking this
stipend was dunkin donuts we actually
put him in the uh crowder jail we'll
check back with him in a little bit um
really quick though uh and of course we
don't want to celebrate the misfortune
of anyone else
beto is sick robert francis he's a sick
man he's a sick man in the head what but
he's as my french gang and grandfather
would say he would say you're six malad
and i didn't find out until like after
he died that he was trying to say
malad means sick he was trying to say
you're sick malad but he would say
you're six malad so i was like what does
six sick mean i didn't understand
and you say it all the time you have six
that's what he meant if you're a
psychopath you go you're six malad man
what okay but that's beto so beto is
sick but now he's actually contracted an
infection that has knocked him off the
campaign trail for a while uh according
to o'rourke he uh is resting he said i'm
sorry i've had to postpone events
because of this but i promise to be back
on the road with you as soon as do you
notice that o'rourke and zuckerberg and
like elizabeth holm they all talk that
same way they do that talking this way
as though it makes me seem articulate
you threw a woman in there and it threw
me off but i'm like yeah they all sound
the same
it also sounds like that woman who made
up the blood yes i'm saying elizabeth is
at home yeah
okay so i just said the same thing as
you yes but it's because that's because
you have brain problems that weren't
identified through thoranus i see yes it
pretty much just went to my offshore
account i see it's i'm afraid of needles
yes ah i have a black turtleneck
just like steve jobs yep moving on
by the way i could use a job
yes i'm in jail so here's what's funny
about this
we'll move on from this quickly without
pandering at all beto
he thanks the team at the methodist
hospital in san antonio i don't know
maybe you find this funny maybe you
don't i do
he tweeted out the extraordinary team
there from custodians to nurses and
doctors gave me excellent care and
attention including iv antibiotics and
so okay i understand i understand the
thanking doctors and nurses right yes
the custodians
well he
what does that even what about the
administrators i mean if you're going to
do the custodians i mean thank the
concierge hey you know you know where i
can get a good iv oh well there's a
wonderful if you go straight down take a
left on uh on shelter boulevard you will
find yourself a bag of needles oh nice
i'd like to thank everyone who works in
the healthcare profession at aetna the
custodians it's just the pandering that
takes place from the oh my gosh
just say thanks you gave me an iv you're
the true heroes blah blah blah blah move
on down the trail the custodians the
accountants make the news you're
attempting to be good yeah your attempt
to be an everyman is just the saddest
thing ever at all costs
the custodians
i like to thank the chimney sweeps and
the window washers yes
i hope i hope everybody in texas shows
up and votes him like the worst of the
defeats that he's had and that would be
saying something because he ran in 2020
i'd like to thank the milkman yeah and
the blacksmith are you just thanking
jobs that don't exist random know that
you know what jobs are around now do you
even know the muffin man i do i like to
personally i'd like to thank him the guy
who
rings the bell there right
anyway i just thought it was funny beto
francis oh okay
uh what's that noise what is that oh
it's coming from the the letter of
crowder jail
[Music]
i'm hungry
i want food
what is that
what is that
[Music]
[Music]
all right
guys i'll give you specific instructions
to not feed him but yeah
that'll last him for a good eight
minutes brian stelter uh
we don't have too many sponsors here in
the show but bill i actually talk about
this it's something i actually eat bars
are great if you want to avoid sweets no
one needs protein bars they're delicious
they can replace like your chocolate
bars go to built.com use a promo code
crowder15 you get 15 off they're made
with oh that's right this is the birth i
don't don't get the birthday cake come
on some people it's the only box left
because we eat all of them at the studio
anymore i don't like the birthday it's
the only one i don't like well i hate
birthdays if you're in a stealther
but i don't like birthday cake period if
that makes seltzer stronger we are all
in for it yes then he might be as strong
as the strongest girl at a 14 year old
slumber party yeah
you're easily you're gonna get hit with
a pillow like you wouldn't believe it's
gonna be loaded with ball gags though
yes
all right
here's something else now again for
double standards while we're talking
about cnn and we're talking about fbi
we're talking about facebook
this morning this happened and it is as
predictable as can be uh cnn uh their
new day show
it's always a new day yeah new day
that's where what's his name that acosta
guy does the reality check oh which is
the opposite of a check of reality he's
like and donald trump is a fascist he's
just like pinochet this has been your
reality he always points at the camera
like this right like he's doing like the
sideways gangster thing right this has
been your reality i hope one day he just
accidentally flashes the wrong gang
symbol and someone at home is inspired
to get off their couch and give him a
talking to a talking too
he does it when he's swatted yes
that's terrible yeah you know we'll
spread it around a little bit tim poole
gets swatted
four times yeah cnn they can get one
yeah come on one swatting come on be a
team player they're like now we know
that's cnn they're all criminals we're
fine with it right yeah so this morning
on new day uh they were going over
comments made by lindsey graham and of
course they uh i want to be really clear
about this they've done this with us
they've done this with donald trump
they're now going to do this with
lindsey graham there is a consistent not
just a double standard right everyone's
a hypocrite often there's a double
standard because you look at the world
through your own bias lens i understand
that this is something where people are
deliberately subverting the truth in
trying to present they can be uh
colloquialisms they can be just sort of
they can be terminology abbreviations
they can be expressions that these
people use themselves but they want
to hold you accountable for them as
though they are literal comments when
you make them the same can be said here
when they actually call for riots they
actually call for violence they've done
so and we'll get into that in just a
second here we have other clips from
maxine waters i feel like we almost run
her clips too often because she's just a
gift that keeps on giving violently
but they want to act as though when
someone else on your side
is simply commenting on or observing
what's happening in this country that
you are of course making an active call
to violence so here's cnn's new day
trying to do this with lindsey graham's
comments
senator lindsey graham says people would
take to the streets if former president
trump is indicted for have for
mishandling classified documents
if there's a prosecution of donald trump
for mishandling classified information
after the clinton debacle which you
presided over and did a hell of a good
job there'll be riots in the streets
with us now cnn political commentator
and host of cnn's murkonish michael
smercottis michael great to see you mary
mccord who was on adriana earlier this
morning said when she heard that it
sounded to her like an implicit threat
someone told me who told someone else
who saw uh
their girlfriend's sister's cousin's
boyfriend who knows this guy perception
of a double standard that was fueled in
part by mark zuckerberg in the last
couple of days talking about how
facebook was approached by the fbi in
the 11th hour of the last campaign
saying be on the lookout for russian
misinformation or disinformation whether
these are apples and apples we can
debate but there is a perception that
when it was hillary when it was hunter
biden it gets handled differently than
when it's donald trump there's no
perception i'm worried about what
lindsey graham is saying so hold on a
second i'm worried about what he's
saying because of a person no
there's no perception
how do we know that the fbi told them
that the hunter biden story was missing
because the
president the creator of facebook said
the fbi told him there's this uh there's
this interpretation there's this
perception this in one case they go it's
a perception right so they've now taken
facts off of your side of the ledger
they haven't actually refuted them
they've just taken them off by saying
there's this perception no no it's what
happened right beyond any shadow of a
doubt and then they try and present
their conjecture as facts there's this
perception but now this woman stated
emphatically that this is an implicit
call to violence see that sleight of
hand that takes place and then they use
that to ban you yeah and i don't know if
this is an apples to apples comparison
hey you got that one right one is the
president of the united states who
controls what's classified and what's
not and didn't have his documents hacked
or taken by foreign entities the other
was not the president of the united
states did not have access to or have
rights to have those documents on a
private server at home that was hacked
by foreign entities that was then
scrubbed and then she said no no problem
and also hillary clinton has no power to
declassify no it's not at all so yeah of
course it's not apples to apples so it's
more like apples to your [ __ ]
i like apples i like apples too i don't
like them apples what's your favorite i
like a honey crisp i like a fuji yeah
you get like a good fuji grandma smith i
like i like gala yeah you know what i
don't like new day apples
nope how you like them apples
michael's murmur mckermish
this piece of sh went on to discuss the
possibility that graham was trying to
actually also not only implicitly call
for violence
and you know so they always say someone
else told me someone else said that this
seemed like a call to violence or a a
blatant threat was the term they used
from lindsey graham none of them want to
hang their hat on it and say this sounds
like a threat to me they say someone
else one of our reporters said this and
they'll go to that reporter later and
that reporter won't say it they'll blame
somebody else right but then they did
try and say that lindsey graham is
saying this in stating something that is
a very real possibility that he was
trying to influence
the outcome of the election the
gaslighting continues i think the harder
issue here is how is merrick garland
supposed to evaluate that
information and what i mean is that
traditionally a prosecutor takes a look
at a case and decides is there
sufficient evidence for me to prosecute
a crime can i win it no and now this set
of circumstances there's an additional
criteria it seems in fact the new york
times in that huge editorial that they
ran this weekend said merrick garland
also needs to determine whether it would
be wise to bring a prosecution if
there's a fear of civil unrest
should that enter into garland's
decision-making i would argue no because
we can't have prosecutors making
decisions based on polling data or the
prospect of civil unrest because then
the rule of law disintegrates
here's the thing i actually agree with
that last point yeah
but that's not what lindsey graham was
doing no and i don't even like lindsey
graham he's a wiener
yeah he's very unpleasant yeah
like i don't hate him he's just a wiener
that's the only way i can describe it
i'm not a fan
you can comment below does that it's
just someone in my head i just see him
like weiner and he's talking and i hear
womp bop bop bop wiener wiener wiener
that's all i hear i just can't stand
with lindsay it's very effeminate when
he talks yeah like too much exactly like
he's an effeminate and he's angry yes
exactly he's like i can't believe
there's guys in my neighborhood look i
feel like he has pecan sandys in his
desk drawer not pens but pecan sandy
yeah i just eat a lot of pecan sandies
and when i'm done i'm done it's a
southern thing you wouldn't understand
we say y'all and we don't have pens in
our desk we have pecan sandies what i
have an oral fixation ever since i quit
smoking i got something in my mouth and
i never smoked
so
i agree though with the point i agree
with the point that yeah they shouldn't
be making a decision based on the
potential of civil unrest correct that
being said lindsey graham was not
calling for civil unrest but i'm trying
to think if there would be a clear
example of this having happened
at some point uh in recent memory oh
wait that's right
maxine waters actively calling for
violent escalation during the shavin
trial if she didn't get the outcome that
she wanted
we are looking for a guilty verdict
you're looking for a guilty verdict okay
and we're looking to see if all of the
talk
that took place and has been taking
place after they saw it
pebble's dress face mask if nothing does
not happen then we know
of that we've got to not only stay in
the street but we've got to fight for
justice but i am very hopeful
and i hope
that we are going to get
a verdict that they say guilty guilty
guilty what should protesters do
well we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more active we've got
to get more confrontational we've got to
make sure that they they know that we
need this okay hold on a second before
you guys jump in
i don't want to do what cnn does
and say that she meant fight literally
even though at that point they had been
fighting literally throughout the
streets
and i don't want to say when she
answered very clearly what we need to do
is get more confrontational right as
though she meant that literally and i
don't want to say that the
the correlation equals causation but uh
of course um regardless of the verdict
her constituents did this anyway
well i'll be darned i thought she meant
like a dance-off yes you know i like
that she had my underwear on her
either face or halle berry's dress in
the flintstones
[Laughter]
and then she said harass everybody in
diners wherever they go
lindsey graham is saying look if
citizens believe that there is an unfair
prosecution in this country you could
see civil unrest and you know why they
would believe that because it's an
unfair prosecution if it happens hey by
the way pause the just throw this all
out sorry i didn't mean internet no
you're fine it's just stupid
presidential records
none of what they said matters none of
why they went into mar-a-lago matters at
all the president is under no obligation
to turn documents over swiftly he can do
it later a librarian asked him for some
stuff he's the president of the united
states they've done this historically
there's always a fight over these
documents
what he's trying to argue too is he's
trying to say this is unprecedented
right and the left is trying to say no
this is business as usual let me tell
you let me give you some examples here
really quickly as to what is
unprecedented okay the espionage act has
not been used against uh against
presidents in the past okay uh there
have not been any presidents who have
been raided for documents this idea that
presidents are not allowed to have
documents that they've uncli that
they've declassified that is
unprecedented yeah what's unprecedented
is of course the prosecution of
political opponents uh when you look at
what the irs when you look at what the
fbi is doing when you look at what the
fbi did with major media outlets let's
just call facebook and twitter what they
are now their publishers their major
media outlets they're not platforms
right all of that is unprecedented
what's not unprecedented is someone
saying hey maybe there was some foul
play in the election why because hillary
clinton did that
the v which election the one before the
one that you're saying we're not allowed
to talk about yeah and then of course al
gore did that and for people who say oh
i'll go over florida george bush look
into that i know a lot of you may not
have done
history remedial a lot of people think
that al gore wanted a recount no he
didn't he wanted it in four specific
counties you wonder
yeah exactly he wanted to make sure he
won the election he specifically fought
a recount which george w bush said let's
recount all of florida no no no i just
want this area so a lot of people aren't
even informed on that and i bet if you
run a search right now on google you
won't actually find out the supreme
court case i think ted cruz actually
played a part in that so while we're
talking about precedent and what's
unprecedented something else i want us i
was about to make it and i think it's
kind of lazy but i think it matters but
you just saw that riot
uh whatever they were burning there but
billions of dollars in damages right the
whole summer of love okay we know that a
lot of people say look at that versus
january 6th
i don't even think we need to make that
comparison when people talk about uh
about january 6
as though it was completely
unprecedented
you don't even need to go so far back to
the riots there is a direct apples to
apples to use michael's drummer in your
minish
comparison there uh smirkaboot they
burned down a church right across from
the white house and stormed the gates
and the president of the united states
donald trump was hidden in the white
house and everyone mocked him saying all
the cowards going to his bunker that was
way worse than they burned a church down
you don't even need to go to the riots
right there a stone's throw away from
what happened on january 6th
there was arson there's violent felonies
that happened and people attempting to
breach the white house and kill the
president and they mocked the president
and we called january 6 the greatest act
of terror in american history we don't
even need to go macro with the examples
of the billions of dollars and the
thousands of of casualties and dozens of
officers who were shot or killed just go
apples apples hey this happened january
okay happened right there in washington
dc yeah only a few weeks earlier they
stormed the gates and burned down a
church right across from the white house
that's worse period we don't hear about
that anymore it's like everyone's
forgotten about it it's been memory hold
well absolutely and i want to make sure
that we're clear about this too don't
don't let the fbi become the biggest of
the boogeyman this is the department of
justice under
joe biden all of this goes back to joe
biden yep that is his biggest political
opponent coming up in the next
presidential election joe biden bad gas
prices terrible economy everything
falling apart in the world it seems
right now russia just continuing to
invade the country we just continue to
send the money they continue to hold
europe
in i guess a vice for the upcoming
winter because they have no gas and heat
right for all their homes that is joe
biden don't lose focus on joe biden
because that's what he wants it's not
just former president trump buddy it's
the guy who would kick his ass in an
election if it were held today oh yeah
just to be clear that's the guy who he's
raiding that's unprecedented two
impeachments based on a sham by the way
there was an impeachment of donald trump
because they said oh yeah russia
trump's not guilty of anything but he's
impeached for something that never
happened right that's unprecedented the
fbi raid is unprecedented lindsey graham
saying you know what there might be
backlash to this is completely
precedented well the reason why january
6 is being used is what other events
you're going to use that even resembles
a riot right well and that's what you
have to use to say that this this kind
of conversation is violence yeah we
can't allow them to talk about these
things because it's violence no it's not
violence at all it's just information
good point to that is they point to
discussing any election irregularities
as dangerous misinformation right and so
that's the only example they can point
to and they try to point to i would
argue while we're doing apples to apples
dangerous misinformation
claiming that the hunter biden laptop
story which uh of course uh
indirectly involves his father the
former vice president united states and
deals with ukraine and china i would say
having that labeled misinformation is
far more damaging than people saying hey
you know what we need to have voter id i
would say
the story that went out that said ashley
biden where she talked about being
molested
and being at least fondled by and
showering with her dad maybe nothing
sexual in her own diet saying that that
was uh fraudulent and russian
misinformation i would say that's more
dangerous than people questioning the
election and you know how i know you
believe that too youtube facebook
twitter
you allowed hillary clinton and amy
klobuchar and elizabeth warren and jimmy
carter and al gore to do it for years so
while we're doing apple's apples
comparison i think the dangerous
misinformation is that which is
verifiable which has changed the outcome
of our country and you know what let me
say this i've never said this is going
to sound like i'm a prick and sometimes
i am
i think the best case scenario is that
uh conservatives people like you right
now watching that you've been
responsible fiscally and that you can
wait it out
and that the next couple of years hurt
like hell for the people who voted for
it i want the people who voted for this
[ __ ] to say god i can't afford to i
can't afford to drive to work i can't
afford to buy to buy chuck roast let
alone to buy top sirloin this is a prop
the rent prices are going up look at the
interest rates i think that these people
need to experience the sting
so that they can remember how good we
had in this country regardless of
whether you have an r or a d next to
your name it needs to sting and we need
to whether that's that's the perfect
world scenario i i don't want it i don't
want hardships for any of you out there
but i think that this country needs to
feel it right now give unto us a king
you said cnn is uh and they're talking
about lindsey graham right now the riots
in the streets okay let's see if they
pull this [ __ ] he might be right uh
there's a we have lots of reasons to
believe that many of uh mr trump's most
ardent supporters might decide to resort
to violence and see how people responded
to just the information that his
residents has been searched so i think
it's it's definitely there's no violence
that i know of national security
officials
however if the department of justice
makes the decision to not prosecute a
former president when the facts in the
law indicate that that prosecution
should go forward
they decide not to simply because
they're afraid of how that uh former
president's supporters might react
without pushing this narrative in real
time i know it's been real
and i don't think that that is an
acceptable result under any
circumstances despite what the threats
or the conflagration or the public
outrage might be those are all things
that we need like you just explained it
i'll tell you exactly why they're doing
this right well i want to hear what uh
yeah sorry about what no i want to hear
what the the ben kingsley uh mr peabody
has to say my personal opinion on it but
uh if you go in and say give me the
reverse botox under my chin can you do
that please watching it can i look like
i'm frowning all the time please
he looks like his bees good to have you
both what what did you say
she said the law should be applied the
same to everyone
really i really wanted to hear what that
other guy said because i imagine his
bees would sound like
a butter buffalo
boom point
here's why they're doing it it's
checkmate
this is exactly why they're doing it
right now
what do you think people do
when pardon my language
you [ __ ] everything up okay we've talked
about this before the timeline with the
mar-a-lago rate okay the raid happens no
the timeline before that is donald trump
was actually complying with them
whatever you need had handed over
documents that okay great just let us
know what you need instead they decided
to go in there and uh and of course they
blame donald trump say the only reason
you know about us because donald trump
tweeted about it well he was tweeting he
was put posting on truth social because
you violated the law and didn't actually
allow them to read the warrant and this
was concerning this shouldn't happen in
the dark you knew that he was going to
do that okay so this happens that's
completely unprecedented then what
happened is everybody said actually
merrick garland doesn't know anything
about this he came out late we said that
on this show yeah we were factually
inaccurate because garland lied then he
came out later said ah actually i was
the one who personally called it trying
to act like he's like the strong
authority figure and he said and we're
gonna unseal the information so long as
donald trump agrees to it
everyone said mike dropped and donald
trump said okay unseal all of it how
about the reason for the effort david oh
you don't want them to find all your
child porn so
[Laughter]
they said no no we can't do that we
can't do that uh unsealed because it
would actually it would it would
interfere with the security of witnesses
okay they said all right let's just
redact it so then they said no that
would take too long then they release
some redacted pages i guess that you see
out there they released the thing but
it's mostly red it's entirely redacted
so nobody can actually see what's going
on and no one can know if this is
actually justified at this point
and if they prosecute them
people are going to be pissed and they
probably are going to take to the
streets now knowing conservatives
knowing people on the right it'll be
almost entirely i would assume if not
completely entirely non-violent they
certainly won't be waging war against
their fellow citizens like the black
lives matter protesters or maxine waters
herself uh
where do you expect them to go you said
we're gonna do this we're gonna do that
right you lied about all of it and now
where we are today what are we the 29th
yes yep we're the 29th of august
the raid happened
two and a half weeks ago something like
that two and a half weeks ago okay let's
call it let's call it 15 days ago
we know
zero more about the justification for
the raid today than we did back then but
we've had at least
a dozen promises that we were going to
be given the information
and it was going to seal right it would
be the final nail in the coffin we know
nothing more than we knew back then
now imagine today goes into tomorrow and
they decide to prosecute the man who we
know would beat the [ __ ] out of joe
biden in an election
of course there would be unrest yeah not
because of of systemic racism that can't
be described and people using it as an
excuse to go and and steal a
westinghouse
but because people are saying you told
us that you would let us in on why you
are doing this if there were crimes so
egregious
it threatened the security of our
nation-state yeah
we know nothing more today than we did
the day the raid happened well you
wouldn't think that from watching cnn
because what they've been putting out
there is oh my gosh nuclear information
that maybe could fall into the wrong
hands by the way so far maybe maybe he's
selling it into the hands and there's
other stories and timelines out there
where he asks for this information about
informants and then we start losing
informants around the world being killed
i wonder if donald trump is is paying
off business favors but
all of that ran
everybody got to hear about that even
though there's no evidence of any of
that and by the way he said something
he's like they shouldn't be afraid you
shouldn't be afraid if you're applying
the law equally you should be terrified
if you are not that the people will not
stand for it i'm sorry that's not how
this country works you don't get to run
roughshod over the american population
and go you just have to take it that's
not how we do business here no you
should be terrified and i'm not saying
that you would come across physical harm
i'm saying that you would lose your jobs
that you guys would be run out of
business you should be terrified of that
yeah
what should happen next the next
president of the united states if they
are republican and if republicans if
they take the house the senate what
needs to happen next is because people
before saying hey can be used against
you well guess what
we need to start using it against them
there needs to be prosecution to the
fullest extent of the law insider
trading
any kind of election meddling that's
happened or any kind of irregularities
any changing of the election laws that
violate the state constitutions
any any type of uh international
relationships like we see with joe biden
in ukraine that requires an
investigation there should be full
investigation and prosecution of
everyone and it should happen with
complete transparency and no rejections
that's what the next republican needs to
do and i won't vote for anyone or
support anyone who doesn't promise to do
it there's no more playing nice
they take the low road we take the high
road no no no there's only one road
there's only one road right now and
they're driving like [ __ ] in the
fast lane slowing the rest of us down
because the rest of us just actually
want to get back on the road to freedom
and and we can't because we have an 87
000
increased irs force we have the fbi who
now have more power over the american
public than ever before and instead of
paying for i don't know border security
instead of paying for i don't know
ensuring that we have uh the most
effective military in the world instead
of ensuring that we have elections with
integrity instead of spending money on
those things what are we doing
well we're forgiving uh we're forgiving
student loans for people who got gender
studies degrees
yeah
that's where we are in this country yeah
that's a legitimate role of government
you need to understand the legitimate
purview of government if you're going to
look at any of this and be as terrified
as you need to be look we i will tell
you this there's a silver lining
and a lot of these issues that are
happening today
we might be we might be beyond the bend
with some of it
even heard me say that before
if this if this continues to go on
completely unchecked
we cannot have a country where the fbi
can selectively prosecute
can selectively enforce the law
and selectively tell all major media and
big tech outlets what they're allowed to
cover
that cannot be allowed to stand and we
need that's again why lindsey graham is
a little bit of a wiener we need better
than lindsey graham in there and we need
you all of you to fight for every single
inch all the time reduce your dependency
on big tech
right you need to start voting with your
dollar and i know it's hard it's hard
because unfortunately the left gets
their hands into everything but there
are good local businesses that you can
support you can get involved in your
local politics and what i will say
beyond anything you know what the best
thing is that you can do
is just stop going
let your freak flag fly
honestly don't be shy if someone says oh
well donald trump just say oh [ __ ] you
you know this is this is ridic it's a
sham
you know what i have plenty of friends i
could use a few enemies leave my you're
not welcome at my barbecue i'm done with
it no more cocktail parties with these
people not when they're this far gone by
the way it's a live show monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern i would love for
all of you to watch on rumble or you can
listen to the audio on apple on android
but rumble and of course mug club the
promo code is uh free speech yes free
speech you get 30 off we take your chat
we have a whole story now we've gone
late yeah uh what what manatee taiyo i'm
gonna kill you i think
is it manatee tail it's so nice you know
what we'll figure out what the name is
but we're gonna go to mug club and he'll
he'll inform me probably wrong i'm
pretty sure it's manatee
[Music]